so we're certifying an aviation vehicle
as a boeing
to perform five dollar deliveries and
solving that is is a lot of fun
uh you can do dole deliveries today for
100 bucks 500 bucks a delivery that's
easy
building a system that would be
autonomous enough and today our drones
are
if you compare them to cars they're
cutting out with five autonomous
speakers
there's no joystick no remote nothing
all in operator has to do is press the
green button that's it the door knows
where to go you don't have to point on
the map
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this one is going to be amazing
we're going to be talking about drone
deliveries from somebody who sent a
spaceship to the moon
literally meet yariv bash the co-founder
and ceo of flytrax and founder of space
iel
erief bosch is the ceo and co-founder of
flytrax a drone technology company
providing comprehensive autonomous drone
delivery solutions
that enable any business from small
businesses to e-commerce
giants to integrate instant autonomous
drone delivery
into their offering flytrax is an
end-to-end drone logistics solution
spearheading the drone revolution prior
to flight tracks
yariv was the founder and ceo of space
iel
a 100 million dollar israeli non-profit
organization that attempted to lend
bereshit
the first private inter-plenary robot
mission on the moon
welcome to 20 minutes later happy to be
here thank you for having me
actually you're here but yeah i am here
this is amazing i am in the flight
tracks aviation offices
and what we don't see behind this door
are a fleet of some of the coolest
drones i've ever seen
and and i'm so proud to be a tiny tiny
part of this journey
and this is just amazing what you're
doing here before we talk about drones
and how you're literally changing
consumer behavior forever
you're a part of this huge movement
playing with some of the biggest players
in the world
and but the obviously the best and i
want to learn a little bit about you
the engineer in you because even without
fly tracks
from your kind of the military and
through mahanet
and through belashit and now
you are the definition of an engineer as
far as i can tell but
tell me a little bit about how you think
through this persona
uh well i tend to yeah i just love to
create stuff and
creating you can be you know a painter
you can be a a poet but you can also be
an engineer or
a software developer and as long as you
uh as you create uh
for me that's the the fun part uh today
i'm you know mostly managing we've got
more than 40 uh employees at flytrax
but still you're you know you're
creating something
flighttracks as a whole is creating
something that might
possibly make a dent in the world so uh
that's part of the fun
you know whatever happens with it
already is making a dent because it's a
part of a huge movement that is
literally
shifting regulations left and right is
doing some incredible incredible things
take me back to your army base this idea
of creation
a lot of people say they like to create
but you created something
that is now enabling hundreds and
hundreds
of other engineers to create tell me
about it so actually my military service
i
i was a fighter in a special forces unit
in the artillery cops not many know that
and after that i joined as a student to
the uh
prime minister's office and i i was
basically basically an employee rather
than a soldier over there
wow and after a few years we uh visited
the aussies about the
yossi valdez kinelet and we told you
listen yo see we want to do the same
kind of camp for the prime minister's
office
and he told us listen guys there was
another guy here from a different branch
of the
pmo and there was an air force commander
here why don't you all meet up together
and create something for the
entire defense forces and uh secret
service agencies and all those guys
together
and that's how we we formed bachanet at
the end wahanet
is a creativity camp your entry ticket
is a project
and that project has to be smart and
useless why useless
basically we want to enable creativity
we want to enable you to learn and
experience new things
that you usually don't do on your
day-to-day so if you're a software
programmer
you can play with electro with
electronics with hardware if you're a
carpenter you can code
and you can go back to your unit
empowered by new skills
and that multi-discipline really helps
uh
on top of that if you'd work on top
secret projects then you know if someone
if let's say you're from the mossad
and someone from the navy would like to
join uh
we're sorry it's top secret you can't
really it's right we will be using that
later on
so the whole idea is to let you just
have fun
think outside the box learn something
new
and meet people that are as creative and
crazy as you are
so you know that you're not alone in the
big
you know in in it's the biggest system
in israel
now walk me through if i would if if
anybody that assistant were coming to an
event
what did they see what does it look like
uh
oh it's been called the theme park for
engineers
uh basically it's a three-day event you
barely sleep
there's so much it's like you know it's
like going into a candy store
as a kid you'll always feel bad because
you can't
taste everything and see everything and
it's the same thing you've got hundreds
of people
uh in teams it could be a single person
a few persons sometimes
more than a dozen working on crazy
projects uh we've had really everything
we had
projects from a water slide simulator
which
spins you inside and tilts you and your
in your batting you know
you're inside it in water uh we had a
jet pack above the pool once
uh we have small projects like there was
a guy who built like an
alu a small computer uh we when the
logic units were based on water
rather than electronics uh we had a team
building
a toilet that runs after you
we once said someone built like a uh an
automated the soccer goalkeeper
and and it was like actually a video of
like the air force commander that came
for a visit
time to score and after he left we uh we
had a few reporters uh
in one of the years they told them ask
him so how did he do and he said oh that
guy i think he's okay he didn't even
recognize
he's the air force commander because wow
everybody is you know on civil closing
there's no
no ranks there's nothing and and the
dissonance is that you know this happens
during the week these defense units
whose
time is so valuable they're taking their
best soldiers
putting them in this camp and let's
think in the beginning it was really
hard
not just to get the budget from the
different units but also to get
some days from the best people and also
to explain this is not a
a trophy this is a creativity camp to
empower your most creative ones
it's not a trophy camp for the uh for
the best project
right and in the beginning of in the
first few years we had to like
we got recommendations from others and
we hand-picked and we
literally went to uni commanders asking
for a specific person
and sometimes the unit commander would
tell us that guy
he's a mess it's it's chaos why do you
want him i've got
amazing other people that you can have
and no no we want that guy
so it was how to fine-tune the camp at
the beginning
and i just want to add one one project
to the list a robot that flips pancakes
and i remember i spent days and nights
with my friends
in our robotics lab from high school the
energy we had
knowing that we're building something
that is completely useless not nothing
close to anything that could be even
commercialized but
knowing that we're bringing to the
events that we can flip pancakes and we
have a great picture with the
way i believe the head of the police at
that moment and it it's just so surreal
and it is it was incredible fast forward
to the sheets
we're still not at fly tricks one of
israel's
greatest accomplishments forever i think
because it
it was i remember the beyond the
commercials and empowerment
the sensation behind this what what was
it
uh so for me it was
again in a way of making an impact
both on on the world when it comes to
space exploration and both
on israel with our educational program
for a program
special is a not-for-profit educational
organization so it's a
wheelchair organization that sends a
spaceship to the moon yeah and
98 of the budget is dedicated to
spacecraft
uh two percent is dedicated to to the
education but
the important thing that this is like
you know marketing the butterfly effect
and it's you know it's we didn't have to
prove that but because it already
happened
during the 60s the apollo days
it was called the apollo effect it made
kids go into
science and technology and engineering
in growing numbers
so we knew we can do that and back then
it was a side effect for us it was
one of our main goals so it's already
impacting kids
and as we're you know gathering up and
raising everything we need for the next
one
it's going to be even crazier and and
you know it's uh if we
we crashed with one this time you know
we're just we're building three
wow so there's gonna be an orbiter
and it will release two landers oh my
god and that's another
one of the first things that you know
first so
uh we will see how it goes i'm getting
and i'm seeing my blood shoot up and
down just hearing about this
and by the way uh space hell started
because of muhammad
so back in 2010 we had the president
perez visiting us at the camp
and besides organizing the camp i always
love to make one of the uh
like the project the gift project that
everybody gets and
back then my project was like a tag that
sends your id and receives everybody
else's id in the vicinity and every time
you go to the uh
to lunch or dinner we milk everybody all
the data so we know
who's been with who oh my god and at the
end of the event we send the beacon to
everybody and it turns into an arduino
uh and we gave shimon peres one of those
and then we i said okay what do i want
to do for next year and i thought about
building a rocket
uh launching it to the edge of space
releasing uh you know a small
plastic spacecraft and calling it the
first israeli spacecraft
oh my god and i went to a friend's house
and he told me i was not thinking big
enough
what about you know the x-files and i
told the villain
cost of the camp is like a few hundreds
of thousands of shekels maybe i know
100k in dollars what are you talking
about going to the moon but
luckily my friend has a wide selection
of scotch
and as i stole the streets of tel aviv
back home he lives nearby i just you
know i said i said okay
if i'd open the israeli team at the
competition how should i name it and
that night i registered the space.com
domain name
oh my god and post it on facebook who
wants to go to the moon
so uh that's how we got started what is
it like
working years on for a moment in the end
and then it's a moment but it's much
more than that
what does it do to you as an engineer
but also as an entrepreneur
i have to say i didn't cry when the
space half crashed for me
it was an amazing journey uh if you
wanna
compare it to something then it was
going to the olympics for the first time
and getting a silver medal
wow so for me it was a huge
accomplishment
with everything that we've achieved and
showing the world that you can do a deep
space
mission as a private organization and
for a lot less
so for us you know we've achieved a lot
and the journey was you know i wouldn't
want to spend
my days any other way so the journey was
amazing
and you know when we got started we uh
multi-shelf the sheriff's piano agency
they've been working for us for bono for
many years
and we moti is actually one of his
expertise is managing crisis
so when we started we asked him what
happens if we crash
on the moon and he said that's going to
be amazing and what are we talking about
he said
all of israel will be holding their
hands for you uh while you're building
another one it's going to be an amazing
dramatic story so
uh we'll see i'm i'm getting
interested just just thinking about the
amazing journey that the drawing
and i'm so jealous honestly right you
know having the opportunity to work on
the things that you've worked on and we
haven't even reached
where we are today it's every engineer's
dream it's every problem solvers dream
listen if you can find someone to pay
you for your hobby it becomes a job
that really is it now we're here flight
tracks offices
uh you decide that it's not enough to
just do bajanet and just reach the moon
but you're actually going to change the
world in a really meaningful way and it
has a lot of implications beyond just
food delivery it's a new way of of of
opening up
if right now we're thinking in two
dimensions in the world you're really
opening us up to three dimensions that's
how i'm
thinking of it flight tracks so flight
tax is all about
delivering a dinner or an iphone to a
family in the u.s suburbs that's what we
do
we're talking about high volumes lots of
deliveries short ranges just a few miles
or a few kilometers
and low margins i have to perform
deliveries for five bucks
and it's a very interesting engineering
point because
you can't use the consumer drone off the
shelf and and just fly
it's drones we have to make time
it's we have to be certified by the faa
and receive a commercial type
certification
it's the same kind of certification that
boeing or the bus goes to
it's a very lengthy process that takes
three to five years
at the end this is really it's we're
certified as a boeing we have to produce
them as if we're
a small boeing our operators are not
going to be
private people they're going to be
aviation companies operating these
vehicles because they have to stand by
the operations
and maintenance et cetera so we're
certifying an aviation vehicle as a
boeing to perform
five dollar deliveries and solving that
is is a lot of fun you can do dole
deliveries today for 100 bucks 500 bucks
a delivery that's easy
building a system that would be
autonomous enough and today our drones
are
if you compare them to cars they're
cutting out with five autonomous
speakers
there's no joystick no remote nothing
all in operator has to do is press the
green button that's it the drone knows
where to go you don't have to point on
the map
nothing in the recent business insider
article
the famous quote if you haven't if you
have a driver's license you're over
qualified to operate right wrong if you
think about it
if you're driving a one-ton car driving
50 miles per hour
on the road with other people around you
if you sneeze at the wrong time or
your attention is diverted you can find
yourself in a car accident
are drones they're just robots they
continue doing what they're doing
they've got multiple level of
redundancies
and another independent system for
filing a parachute if
lightning strikes and they're just
they're gonna they're not gonna get
tired they're not gonna text their
girlfriend
they're not gonna be you know drinking
and driving
they just perform over and over again in
the same manner
as designed and we've even got
preventive maintenance so
even you know the minute our cloud
system identifies a problem with one of
the drones
before it happens before it becomes a
malfunction we can just recall the
drones back home and and
perform maintenance i just have to set
the context here because i'm looking at
this as an outsider
and you're living it day by day when
we're sitting here what we have behind
the the camera here is a book
if i can say 600 pages actually six
i was gonna it's unbelievable 600 pages
of the manual to explain how this drone
is operating no that's just the
maintenance manual
if you go to the other room there's like
the computation is this high
now everybody is it's we actually had
really it's it's man deviation
certification we have to get the waiver
is to not to put the manuals on the
airplane we have to get an exemption
because we don't need ashtrays or you
know
those kind of things it's just crazy now
we took us to another room where he
showed us
hundreds of parts that together make up
the drone each one of them has to get
approved by the f and i think no matter
how much we'll explain it here
you can't come up you can't push across
the complexity
of this project the way i try to explain
it is listen we've been doing backhand
deliveries in iceland flying above the
city beyond visual website four years
ago
using four years ago using a commercial
dome of the shelton
going from there to a system that's
certified on a national level by the faa
that's four to five years and i know
that because together with me
are companies such as wing by alphabet
or amazon
and we're working with the same office
the los angeles aircraft certification
office the laaco that does
all the unmanned project certification
for the fa they've got i don't know 100
and something projects simultaneously
you know boeing loki those guys as well
so really it doesn't matter if your
flight does from tel aviv or amazon from
seattle
that's the process you'll have to to go
through that
and we're currently seeing as we
progress it's not going to get easier
it's just going to get harder because
the level of safety the uh
we're seeing that with some of the uh um
different tests that we have to go
through the you know
becoming more complex not simpler wow
because at the end you know
aviation is so safe these days and
it's in everybody's interest to make
sure that it stays
as safe as it is today once you open the
shelter
you're opening up a whole new world
literally now
now i want to talk to you the the ceo
and the
the businessman engineering is awesome
but at the end
what you're doing here is you're making
a really big change in the way we think
about
exactly transportation in general what
does that mean to you how is the world
going to be
different you know once flight tracks is
in the market and it's happening on a
day-to-day basis and we accept it as
part of our society
so the way we look at it is we we
envision a future of instant
gratification
today when you you know you log on to
amazon you just click you don't add to
an item to your account you just click
buy now
delivery is ubiquitous to you you don't
pay pay for it or maybe you pay
on a monthly and then you can do as many
deliveries as you'd like
and you will get it next day or usually
you know usually if it's a hot item or
you know popular item next day it's
gonna beat your dough
and drones offer the same kind of
experience we don't demand
so if i need tomatoes for dinner or a
bottle of wine
by now i just saw an ad for the new
iphone click buy now
and 15 minutes it's gonna be in your
backyard so
i it's it's gonna be a lot faster and
cheaper than getting into your car and
driving to the best buy
why do that i can get i can get it
faster than that so
it's and it really opens up a lot of
very cool possibilities we
we will be announcing that in the next
few months but really once you take the
the cost of one demand below a certain
threshold
yeah companies retailers restaurants can
just offer the service for almost free
and then the end customer doesn't have
to think about delivery cost or hidden
fees
or even about tipping the korean guy or
getting dressed and outdoors don't have
any cameras on boat so
no privacy issues that last part is i
think one of the most important pieces
you're touching on
and i i'm already booking you for
another episode because
uh i have to send you to your next
meeting but but
this is incredible and just getting a
little bit into the mind of the engineer
i get so excited by by what you do here
because i can feel this is
your passion and so i can see it it's
funny because
when we are bringing new operators or
pilots
they usually they get bored really fast
because they're not really flying the
the drone
yeah but the engineers are you know it's
crazy i can see just walking here in the
offices
i have three questions for you leave one
okay okay
favorite subject back in middle school
or high school i have to say that my uh
uh favorite time was the uh the time i
realized if i
that if i drop out of physics i'll have
only three days of school
a week and i'll be able to pay to play a
command and conquer and civilization
so uh not sure if that answers your
question but i'll take that that was my
mindset back then
i'll take that and i don't know how but
my parents were okay with that so
somebody who serves as an inspiration
for you a role model of some sort an
inspiration
so i think my first one was my
grandfather
so it's a funny story my grandfather was
a textile engineer
in east europe and he was in hungary
and during the holocaust the nazis took
300 engineers to jewish engineers out of
the
conscription camps to work on the v1 and
v2 rockets on the assembly line
crazy story out of those 300 less than
100 survived
it's called the dryer 100 group
something like that and
uh my grandfather back in the 80's
he actually worked for false organ
walked you know as a conscription
entry but as a first labor
but he he went there and he you know
they gave them a visit and everything so
he made peace with with germany and
everything
and as a kid every time he came back
from europe on for a trip he always
bought me like a kit
diy kit wow a radio a motor where you
have to you know
really you know all the coils and
everything and doing everything on your
own so that was my uh
you know my insight into engineering
unbelievable
and real three words you would use to
describe yourself
um can i start with engineer
uh engineer creator
and good question what's the third one
maybe around enthusiasm and now we're
also at a visionary because what you're
doing
here is you're from this tab office
you're literally going to impact the
world in ways that i think that the
butterfly effect is going to be
tremendous amazing